jaxa is one of the biggest and most
advanced space agencies in the world yet
the general public usually pays little
attention to jaxa the us is known for
being the most advanced the russians are
known for being insanely reliable the
chinese are known for prioritizing
progress over everything and the indians
are known for being extremely cost
effective but japan similar to the
europeans isn't really known for any one
particular aspect don't let that fool
you though
while jaxa may not be the most
interesting for news outlets jax is one
of the most interesting for scientists
so here's the story of jaxa and why
they're so underrated today
taking a look back it all started in the
1950s shortly after world war ii
japan had not only lost world war ii but
they were devastated by the us bombing
that closed out the war to make things
even worse for japan the us and its
allies were occupying japan after the
war and they were keeping japan on a
very short leash
japan was not allowed to have an army
and they weren't technically supposed to
be developing space technology for
military use but as the soviet union
rose in power the allies more or less
forgot about japan and just let them do
whatever they wanted by the 1970s when
the first parts of jaxa were founded in
the 1950s though they were walking a
pretty thin line
so it makes sense that the corps of jaxa
was founded under the premise of
educational research in april of 1955
the university of tokyo launched the
pencil rocket horizontally and this
launch marked the beginning of the
institute of space and astronautical
science or isas
later that year in august the akita
rocket testing center would be
established at michikawa beach this
center would serve as their hub for
testing over the next several years
at first they would experiment with the
pencil and the baby rocket but soon
enough they would move on to their first
major project the kappa rocket japan had
a reasonable goal of reaching 60 to 100
kilometers with kappa but even that
would prove quite difficult at first for
a full year the japanese would try using
a composite propellant with kappa and
the rocket would explode on ignition
every single time
it wasn't until they switched propellant
that they would achieve their first
successful launch with k6 in june of
1958.
following the success isas would create
a much larger version of the k6 called
the k8 in july of 1960 the k8 would
successfully be launched to an altitude
of 190 kilometers which gave japan the
title of making the first ion density
measurement though the allies heavily
limited japan space projects this
limitation was also partially a positive
while the us and russia were racing
towards putting animals and people into
space japan was able to solely focus on
scientific missions this would be one of
their primary reasons for japan's engine
space robotics and research
anyway getting back to the kappa rocket
isas would continue improving their
rocket and reach higher and higher
altitudes in december of 1961 they would
launch a k9 to 300 kilometers and
successfully measure the electron
density and temperature at that altitude
unfortunately the akita testing center
would be closed up in 1962 but the
noshiro testing center would be opened
up soon after
as isas transitioned to a new testing
center they would also transition to two
new rockets called the mu rockets and
the lambda rockets in july of 1964 isas
would launch the lambda l-31 to an
altitude of 1 000 kilometers to put that
into perspective the iss orbits at 408
kilometers that same year isas would
also launch the mt-1351
which was japan's first weather
observation satellite
over the next several years isas would
continue pushing the boundaries with mu
and lambda
in 1967 for instance the lambda l3h3
would reach 150 kilometers though isas
was making rapid progress with the two
rockets isas would find it quite
difficult to put an artificial satellite
into orbit on the first try the mission
would fail due to improper state
separation
on the second try the final stage would
fail to ignite on the third try the
third stage would fail to ignite on the
fourth try the third stage would collide
with the upper stage it wasn't until the
fifth try in 1970 with the l4s5 that
japan would finally put the satellite
osumi into orbit and become the fourth
country to do so
as we all know the us put humans on the
moon just one year before that in 1969
and that success would motivate them to
loosen the restrictions on japan
japan would instantly create their own
national space agency called the
national space development agency of
japan or nasda on october 1st 1969.
unlike isas which was solely focused on
scientific missions nasda was focused on
launch capability
so at this point japan had two
significant space agencies with vastly
different goals
aside from loosening restrictions the us
would hand over unclassified rocket
designs to japan
this gave japan a major boost in terms
of spaceflight development but at the
same time it also hindered japan from
developing their own designs earlier a
year after nasdaq was founded they would
start work on the n1 launch vehicle
the n1 was based on the american thor
delta rocket and was capable of putting
1200 kilograms into low earth orbit the
first n1 would be launched in september
of 1975 and the japanese would complete
a total of seven different launches over
the next several years fun fact the
second launch of the n1 would take place
on february 29 1976 which is the only
orbital launch conducted on a leap day
around the same time nasa started
development of the n2 rocket in october
of 1976 which allowed them to transition
to the n2 as the n1 was retired similar
to the n1 the n2 was based on the
american delta rocket and had a payload
capacity of 2 000 kilograms to low earth
orbit nasdaq completed the first end to
launch in february of 1981
they would complete another seven
launches by the end of 1987 and all
eight launches would be fully successful
in the meantime nas destroyed
development of the h1 rocket and this is
when nasa would take their first steps
away from american rockets the first
stage of the h1 would be modeled off of
american rockets however all of the
upper stages would be designed by the
japanese
the h1 had a payload capacity of 3200
kilograms to low earth orbit and would
complete its first launch in august of
1986. the h1 would complete a total of
nine launches by 1993 all of which were
successful
nasdaq would also work with nasa and
score a couple of seats on the space
shuttle as a result nasda would be able
to select three japanese astronauts in
and mori mamoru would become the first
japanese astronaut traveling to space
aboard the space shuttle in 1992
anyway given the success of the h1
nasdaq would quickly turn around and
start development of the h2 which would
be fully designed by the japanese the h2
used the same upper stages as the h1 and
nasda simply designed their own first
stage to make the rocket fully japanese
nasda didn't just change the nationality
of the rocket though they would also
make it much more powerful than the h1
the h2 had a sizeable payload capacity
of 1060 kilograms to low earth orbit and
it cost 90 million dollars per launch to
put that into perspective the falcon 9
has a payload capacity of 22 800
kilograms low earth orbit and cost 62
million new
so the h2 was about 3.3 times as
expensive as a new falcon 9
but it was 20 years ahead of falcon 9 so
not bad at all
the h2 would end up completing 7
launches by the end of the 1990s five of
which were fully successful
as nasda worked on improving their
launch capability isas was still
chugging along with their greek rockets
throughout the 1970s and 80s isas would
continue launching their mu rockets
filled with experiments and data
collecting satellites they collected
critical data on the sun the environment
and various asteroids as nasa progressed
though isas quickly faded into the
background we didn't see any new rockets
or anything particularly exciting don't
get me wrong here isas was still
gathering extremely important data
but given the dense technical nature of
their experiments and data there's not
too much to discuss
moving into the new century japan would
decide that it was inefficient to
operate multiple space agencies
separately
as a result in 2003 they would choose to
combine the three biggest space agencies
in japan which were nasda isas and the
national aerospace laboratory
nasda brought advanced launch technology
isis brought expertise in space research
and the national aerospace laboratory or
null well they were there too
null had actually been around since 1955
and specialized in aircraft and rocket
research but they didn't actually build
anything
at one point they tried to make a space
plane called the hopex but that didn't
quite pan out
so the superstars in the collaboration
were definitely nasta and isas
and with that jaxa was created and japan
became one of the strongest space powers
in the world since then jax has
completed a countless number of
exploration and research missions so
we're going to have to speedrun through
these starting with lunar and
interplanetary missions we have hayabusa
hayabusa was a mission to a nearby
asteroid called 25143 irekawa this
spacecraft was launched in may of 2003
it reached the asteroid in november 2005
and it brought back samples in june of
2010. next up jackson launched their
lunar orbiter kaguya in september of
2007.
this was the most significant lunar
mission since the apollo program
in december of 2010 japan attempted to
insert akatsuki into orbit around venus
unfortunately this mission would fail
but japan would try again in 2015 and
succeed
in august of 2004 jax had deployed two
solar sails at varying altitudes in july
of 2005 jaxa would launch an x-ray
telescope in a mission called suzaku in
january of 2006 jaxa would launch an
advanced land observation satellite in
2008 jaxa launched a greenhouse gas
observing satellite and in 2007 japan
delivered the kibo space module to nasa
which is the largest single iss module
that was just 8 of jax's most notable
missions they have dozens upon dozens
more
looking forward jaxa plans to play an
integral role in artemis the lunar
gateway a lunar mission with india and
of course a plethora of research and
experimental missions as you can see
jaxa has been one of the biggest
background players in the space industry
but they are often overlooked by the
media because they don't deal with human
space flight they don't do the exciting
launches to the iss or the moon
but their scientific contributions to
the space industry are just as important
and who knows maybe jackson has
something up your sleeve when it comes
to human space flight do you think jaxa
deserves more recognition comment that
down below
also drop a like if you agree that jaxa
is underrated and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one